>>Reto Meier: So good morning, everyone.
Thanks for coming along to the session.
It's great to see a huge turnout.
My name is Reto Meier.
I'm the developer advocate on the development
team at Google.
I'm going present to you today, hopefully,
Protips on how to build expert apps for Android.
Before we get started, we've got a couple
housekeeping notes.
We've got the session feedback.
For those in the audience who want to give
feedback either during or preferably at the
end of the session, please don't take the
advice of the previous session and give their
bad advice to me.
Maybe save it all up for the next session.
For those of you who are at home watching
via the YouTube stream, you can ask questions
via the moderator link, which is up there.
And, hopefully, we'll be able to get to some
of those by the end of session as well.
So this is supposed to be an expert session.
A 301.
And it's a packed room.
I think I need to ask how many of you consider
yourselves to be expert Android developers?
That's a majority.
Excellent.
Hopefully, this will help get you there.
For those of you who did, hopefully, there's
going to be some stuff here that you will
find interesting and new.
I should warn you there is a lot of code in
this presentation.
Don't feel like you need to scribble it all
down now.
The recorded video and the slides will be
available for your copying and pasting pleasure
pretty quickly after I/O.
So don't feel like you have to scribble it
down now.
So as experts, what do you think is the most
common question that I get asked by bury other
expert developers?
I can tell you that more than any single technical
question, the most common thing I get asked
is how do I get featured?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah?
I'm sure plenty of you asked me this yourselves.
How do I get featured?
How do I rank more highly, and how do I show
up in search results?
The answer is both pretty simple and quite
complicated.
I'm going to try to cover both of those things
today.
Let's start by putting this into a little
bit of context.
How many of you have apps in the Android market?
Keep your hands up.
If you don't want your app featured, you can
put your hand down.
What that represents is a graphic that looks
a little like this.
Pretty much every app wants to be featured.
I tried to make it to scale, but the half
pixel didn't render.
What's left is a group of people who don't
know about featuring.
Awesome.
The tiny sliver are apps which are already
featured.
So let's have a closer look at that.
That sliver represents about 30 apps at any
given time.
Now, if you do the math, there's about 150-
I think 200,000 apps now in the Android Market.
There's about 2,000 people in the keynote
this morning, which means, if the keynote
represents the market, one person would have
been featured.
Even in this room we've got a much higher
percentage of quality Android-developers.
Say you're 10 times more likely to get featured.
That means there's two, maybe three apps here
which will be featured.
Look around.
If there's someone else who has a better app
than you, you're already in trouble.
The simple answer is you need to build the
best app in the room.
The slightly more complicated answer is how
do I go about doing that, which I'm hopefully
going to try to show you guys today.
I'm going to start off with some APIs you've
probably already seen, you've already blogged
about.
But I'm going to show you new ways to use
these existing APIs.
I'm going to go through a couple Rookie Mistakes.
I see expert developers do this day in and
day out.
I'm going to put it out there for you guys,
so you don't make the same mistake.
Hopefully the last half hour of the presentation,
if I run vaguely to schedule, is going to
be purely Protips, all code.
So how do you build the best app in the room?
Well, in some ways it's actually really simple.
You build an app that people want.
Things like e-mail, news, maps, these sorts
of apps people have been trying to get this
information onto their phones since long before
phones had Internet connections.
Where it gets a little bit more challenging
is creating apps that people want but they
don't realize that they want.
Good examples -- Shazam, Google Goggles.
How many have played Angry Birds?
How many are playing Angry Birds right now?
That's all right.
I'm not offended.
So what do these apps have in common?
They're apps which are a step ahead of the
game.
Whether it's using microphone API to sample
music or whether it's using video APIs to
do video recognition, or it's just simply
using a high res screen in a great way to
create an immersive game play, they're at
the cutting edge.
What I'm going to talk about today is using
some of the more current APIs, some of the
stuff which is only available in Gingerbread
or, in some cases, Honeycomb.
The reason why I think you guys need to consider
this is you need to create the app which is
better than everyone else's.
It's not just about quality.
It's also about innovation and using these
new APIs as a way that you can be the new
Shazam or new Google Goggles or next Angry
Birds by using really advanced APIs and creating
apps that aren't just things people use on
their shiny new tablets but they're reasons
to go out and buy the tablets to begin with.
But now that you all have tablets, you have
no excuse for not developing the new APIs.
It's not only that.
You also get to take advantage of efficiency
improvements on each of the platforms so each
user is using the most efficient app that
they can.
And it's also a matter of creating the best
user experience so everything is optimized
for what you're using.
Let's look at how you go about doing this.
It's not as difficult as you think to create
applications that work on both smart phones
and new modern OS versions.
This is an activity that I think of as parallel
activity pattern.
What you're looking at here is a simple pattern
where you're creating, essentially, a shim
class.
We start off by looking at what is the version
of the APKs we have.
Do we have -- are we running on Honeycomb?
Do we have shiny new APIs, or are we doing
things on a earlier version?
So all that happens with OnCreate is we're
checking to see whether or not APIs are available
and starting a new activity, a different activity
depending on which level of APIs are available.
So here we call start activity.
What this is doing is meaning this is a shim
activity.
It has no UI.
It doesn't do anything other than launch one
set of parallel activity streams.
Now the good news is that you don't actually
need to have a completely parallel set of
code base.
For the most part your layouts are going to
be consistent.
If you're using the new fragments library,
which is compatible all the way back to 1.6,
most of your UI is going to be encapsulated
into the fragments, which means they're going
to be consistent across the activity streams,
particularly when you're interfacing using
the resources hierarchy.
So you've, actually, only got one set of fragments,
which is using a different layout to display
the same information.
Now, the advantage of this is that, rather
than having to have completely separate sets
of activities, all you need to do is optimize
particular experience.
And so for Honeycomb, as we learned, the Action
Bar, for example, isn't available, isn't backwards
compatible.
So on a Honeycomb device you use the action
bar and animation framework.
And on a pre-Honeycomb device using the same
fragments, but you're having to create your
own activity bar implementation.
So it's a way to, essentially, optimize based
on the level of APIs available.
Now, that's one approach.
The other thing you can do is just use good
old interfaces.
You'll all experts, so you're all at Google
I/O.
So I don't think I need to go into what an
interface is.
But it gives you an opportunity to create
different implementations based on hardware
and software you have available to you.
So this piece of code shows exactly how to
do this.
So we're looking at three different things.
So, if you've got -- what we're trying to
do is find the orientation of the device.
There's a few variations.
The initial version, which was pre-Cupcake,
had a lot of information.
So we check to see if we're still running
pre-Cupcake, which is pretty good effort at
this point.
We're also going to check so see whether we
have a gyroscope, because we can use the gyro
to smooth out orientation changes.
And then the bulk of the class is going to
be instantiate a different implementation
of that sensor listener.
So all the reflection, does the gyroscope
exist, all that stuff can be encapsulated
away in those implementations?
So that's one way is to create, using the
new APIs, something innovative.
The other thing you want to do is build apps
which are really good.
A great way of doing that is by getting real
user feedback.
Now my slides are already out of date.
There's, apparently, over 300 Android devices
available these days.
And in well over 1-, probably 200 countries,
so really something global.
And the ability for you guys as developers
to actually test for all of these devices
and all of these countries is pretty much
impossible.
And the solution to that -- at Google what
we do is we have a system called dogfooding
where we get everyone in the company to use
these new apps or new operating systems.
And we can get a lot of feedback from them.
We have more than 20,000 employees.
And they're spread all across the world.
And they're all within the same corporate
intranet, so it's really easy for us to get
feedback.
It's much more challenging for you guys who
probably have slightly smaller companies.
So one thing you can do to try to get that
feedback is use analytics tracking, not only
in your live version, but in your betas.
So what we're doing in this particular piece
of code is we're going to track exceptions.
So we're going to look to see every time an
exception gets thrown, we're going to track
that.
So we can find out is there clustering?
Are we seeing a particular exception get thrown
a lot in a particular country in a particular
language in a particular device type or just
corresponding to a particular workflow?
So it's all about bug tracking, getting as
much information as possible.
What's a little more interesting, I think,
is actually doing A/B testing using the same
technique.
So we're going to start off just by generating
a random number and splitting people into
one of two groups.
Are they A or B group?
And then, within your own create method, we're
going to set the content type differently.
So it's either going to be an A or B group.
Now that layout can be completely different.
It can be as complicated as having completely
different button layouts -- some in the Action
Bar, some on menu, some on screen.
Or it can be as easy as trying to figure out
which shade of blue your users appreciate
more.
Because we're tracking each of the users based
on the group they're in, we're able to see
how does this affect their engagement?
Are they using your app more?
Are they doing the things which you want them
to do more?
These are the sorts of things which make it
much easier for you to understand how your
app is working.
It's optimizing your beta by getting real
feedback as to how your app is being used,
what the user engagement is and lets you do
that optimization.
If you're going to do a widespread beta of
that kind, good approach is to use the Android
market to do that.
There's a lot of things you should take into
account.
Particularly as soon as you're making it globally
available, putting it on the market, you make
sure that users understand that it is a beta.
Now whether that's by making a private beta
with a log-in code or simply obscuring the
name and making it unclear what the app is,
it's important to set that expectation so
that people know they shouldn't be expecting
a finished product.
They should be expecting frequent updates
and slightly more polished, as you bring it
to market.
I've seen this being done very successfully
with a number of apps launched recently.
and it's helped them to create a better application
based on what people have said rather than
what they've thought.
So, if we are going to do this, you introduce
the idea of the first possible Rookie Mistake
you can make.
And that's not protecting your package name.
Now, as soon as your APK leaves your dev box,
the first thing you should probably want to
do is put that in market because the package
name is unique.
If someone gets your APK, they can upload
it to market and they own your package name.
So now, if you want to launch, you have to
go through this whole hassle.
I've seen this happen before by experts who
should know better.
At the same time, make sure as soon as you've
used your signing key to sign your APK, that
you've backed it up and backed it up again
in another country in a fireproof box.
This is the only way you can update your app.
If you lose the signing certificate, it doesn't
matter who at Google -- you can bump into
Andy Rubin on the street.
He's not going to be able to update that app
for you.
Make sure you keep that certificate secure.
Another big tip, when you create the market
account, don't use your personal e-mail account
or the CEO's e-mail account or the intern
who's doing it after lunch.
That's the account you're going to need to
log into to do updates and changes.
You don't want to have to call someone at
3:00 a.m. on their holiday so you can login
into their personal e-mail account and change
the release text.
Next Rookie Mistake is going to be a little
more technical.
And that's assuming that the device is portrait.
So you're all proud new tablet owners.
So you'll learn firsthand that a lot of these
tablet devices are designed to be used in
landscape mode.
A lot of games developers have said my app,
my game can only be played in landscape mode.
And I'm using the orientation sensors, and
that's how the layout is designed.
So they've done coding.
And okay.
Smartphone at landscape mode is 90°.
So we're going to rotate our accelerometer
logic to take that 90% turn into account.
The thing is you put that on a tablet and
it's at 000, because it's not just the branding
which is orientated in landscape mode; it's
also the orientation sensor.
So now, because you're making that assumption,
you're going to get the orientation 90 degrees
off.
And your game is going to controlled in portrait
mode.
It's actually really easy to get this right.
You get rotation on the display object that's
going to tell you to the nearest 90 degrees
what the actual orientation is.
And then you can simply remap the coordinate
system on the sensor manager so it's always
zeroed out.
So, if you want to lock the device to landscape
for game play, assume it's at zero, check
using the display get rotation and remap the
coordinate systems accordingly.
Another Rookie Mistake we see is people trying
to detect and track a particular device instead
of a particular installation.
There's a lot of good reasons why you want
to track a particular installation.
You want to let people save settings on the
server without having to create a log-in.
That's all great.
What you don't want to do is track a particular
piece of hardware.
Now, there's a few reasons that you shouldn't.
And the first reason is it's actually quite
difficult to do.
You can get telephony manager.
But, if there is no telephony manager, then
it returns null.
You can say okay.
If the telephony manager returns null, then
I'll get the Mac address.
If Bluetooth or Wi-Fi is turned off, that
also returns null.
What's even worse is, with both of these circumstances,
if you wipe the device and give it to your
friends or sell it on eBay and someone else
logs in, it's going to have the same device
number.
So now your settings are being applied to
someone else's device.
And, from a developer perspective, this is
a really bad time.
It has privacy implications as well as usability
implications.
You can use the Android ID field and secure
settings.
It doesn't work reliably prior to Android
2.2.
You're still asking the user for a scary permission.
This device needs access to use your secure
settings.
I've just downloaded Solitaire.
Why on earth do they need access to my secure
settings?
The solution is fairly straightforward.
All you need to do is generate a unique identifier
for the application.
And so that's all that this code is doing.
There's a lot on screen, but this is the only
bit which is really important.
I'm going create a new random universal unique
identifier.
So from this moment onwards, this application
is uniquely identifiable.
So you can score settings, user preferences,
all those sorts of things on the server.
The last Rookie Mistake is a really easy one.
It's a bit of a gimme.
If you've watched the previous session, you'll
note they gave about half a dozen shoutouts
to the Android developer blog.
We're not trying to keep secrets from you
guys.
We love doing Google I/O.
We love doing these sessions.
Day in and day out, each week, when we're
releasing new things or finding new opportunities
to help you guys build better apps, this is
where we're going to put the new information.
It's not on your frequently read list, be
sure to check it out.
That's where all the tips I'm talking about
today will be or shortly appear.
That's the simple stuff.
I'm sure you'll be glad to know.
The rest of this gets slightly more technical.
So, if you're not cool with lots of code on
screen, now is a good time to maybe check
your e-mail, catch up on Twitter.
That's okay, I won't be offended.
That's cool.
So you're all experts.
I assume you already know the deadly sins
which I talked about last year.
You need to make your apps fast and efficient
and intuitive.
And they need to be beautiful and generous,
and you need to use widgets and all that good
stuff.
I've got a few new attributes, which are going
to help you transition from apps that people
really like to apps that people love, that
they rave about and we want to use in Sandbox
and have up on stage in keynotes.
We've got four attributes, and I'll introduce
the first one now.
Oh, wonderful.
I should have pointed out earlier that I am
doing something of an experiment today by
running my presentation off a tablet.
And this is what happens when the tablet reboots
when it tries to play a video on HDMI, which
has only happened once so far, not during
the rehearsal.
So I'm going to have to dance while I wait
for this to reboot.
It's a really nice video, too.
I think you really would have appreciated
it.
[ Laughter ]
Big question is do I try the video again after
the device has loaded?
Give it another shot?
All right.
There's four of these videos, so we've got
four additional chances after this for it
all to go horribly wrong.
Special shoutout to the hundreds of thousands
watching on the live stream.
[ Laughter ]
We'll go through all of these once again.
Consider this review, revision, if you didn't
see them properly the first time.
It's good, because my session actually goes
for about 50 minutes.
So this extra time is really helping me.
Let's try one more time for the first attribute.
Yes!
That doesn't deserve a clap.
That does.
So thank you.
[ Applause ]
With that slight delay, and quite appropriately,
I'd like to introduce the concept of freshness.
So what is a fresh app?
A fresh app is one which is always up to date.
It's an app which you don't have to wait for
things.
You don't have to wait for the orientation
to update.
You don't have to wait for the data to be
up to date.
In fact, in a perfect world, there is no such
thing as an app being too fresh.
Ideally, you're going to have an app which
knows exactly where you are and is going to
have exactly the most current information
for you to see at any given time.
Now, unfortunately, as we're all aware, battery
doesn't last forever.
So a lot of the time what you're going to
have to do is find a compromise between apps
being able to be as fresh as possible and
have a battery that lasts for longer than
two hours.
So what I wanted to introduce to you now is
a couple of techniques for being able to have
a fresher app in terms of location and data.
So let's start with location.
One of the fancy new things which we introduced,
I think it was in Honeycomb, it may have been
Gingerbread, is the passive location provider.
How many of you guys have heard of the passive
location provider?
A decent few, handful.
For those of you who haven't, what this lets
do you is listen for updates in locations
from other apps, and to have them within your
own apps.
So if Google Maps is running in the foreground,
you are able to receive each of those location
updates.
Works exactly the same way as any other location
provider, so GPS or Wi-Fi.
Specify the minimum distance, the minimum
time that you are allowed.
Specify that as the provider, and then request
those location updates.
Because you don't have control over what the
underlying provider is, your app still requires
the find location permission, and then when
do you want to feigned out what the underlying
provider was, you can simply call get provider
on the location object that gets passed into
your location listener.
Something which has actually been around for
quite a lot longer but hasn't received a lot
of use is this idea of being able to use intents
to listen for location updates.
So this is as an alternative to the location
listener, is you can actually specify a pending
intent, and that's what we can see here.
And the most important part here is the action
string, which we're going to broadcast.
So we construct this pending intent.
And then request those location updates.
And instead of specifying a location listener,
we're going to specify the pending intent
which is going to get broadcast.
So now every time the provider which we have
specified receives an update, it's going to
broadcast this intent.
To listen for it works exactly as you'd expect.
You register a new broadcast receiver.
The implemenation, you can see there.
The key part is you are extracting the current
location which is bundled in with the extras
of that broadcast intent.
Now, where things get really interesting is
if you use these in combination.
So now what we can do is actually use intents
to update your location, even when your application
isn't running.
And how is that going to work?
Well, we're broadcasting intents, which means
you can register a manifest receiver which
is going to listen for those updates.
So you will note here that the action we are
listening for is the same action we specified
when creating our pending intent for those
location updates.
If we specify the location provider as a passive
location provider, we have now got a circumstance
where our app can sit in the background, not
even running at all, and then when we've specified
hopefully a pretty conservative min time and
minimum distance for receiving those updates,
our receiver is going to spin up and allow
us to do something with that information.
So all of a sudden you are getting away from
the situation where every time you get to
a location, so you have just used maps or
navigation to find your way to a venue, and
then you have to wait 30 seconds while it
gets the GPS sync and then downloads the nearby
locations or the ability to check in.
So by using this instead, it gives you that
ability to have a much fresher location without
any additional battery cost because you are
relying on someone else's use of the GPS.
Let's take that one step further.
So what we are really trying to do here is
to get fresher results in that circumstance
when you first start up your app.
So even without using the passive provider
of these location intents, there are a couple
of techniques you can use.
The first is simply to check what the last
known location was.
And you will note that I parsed in false here
to get providers, and what this is saying
is I don't care whether the particular provider
is active or not; just return all the providers.
Because if someone has used navigation, gotten
to their destination and turned off GPS, that
doesn't mean that last location received on
GPS isn't useful.
So what we are going to do here is go through
each of the location providers and find out
how accurate was your last reading and when
was it.
If it was ten seconds ago, accurate within
the nearest ten meters, that's useful information.
And that's probably a good enough value for
you to start pulling down the current data,
without having to wait for your first GPS
location update.
Another tip.
Monitor the best provider available.
Even if it isn't currently active.
Users can turn on or off GPS or Wi-Fi with
a simple click of the button on the home screen
so it's important when you are using criteria
to find the best possible provider that you
check to see whether the better provider gets
turned on.
And then you can do that transition seamlessly
without the user having to do anything.
The other thing -- So that pretty much covers
location.
So now we want to have a look at data.
How do we get fresher data?
Generally, when we are talking about data
updates in Android, we're talking about things
happening in the background.
So how frequently do you wake up your app
and have it pull down new data from the server.
Well, generally, again, this is a compromise
between how frequently you want to do it and
how frequently you want the battery to run
down.
So what I'm suggesting here is rather than
doing that as a one-off, you actually make
that variable based on a number of conditions.
We can start off really simply.
So if we're talking about recurring alarms,
you actually have two options.
It can be a wakeup alarm or a nonwakeup alarm.
A wake alarm is going to spin up the device
even if it's in spanned by mode just so you
can do what you need to do.
So this is a great way of making sure your
app is up-to-date but it does have an impact
on your battery life.
A nonwaking alarm is still going to get triggered,
but it's not going to wake the device out
of standby until it's out of standby itself.
So if you say every 30 minutes and the user
doesn't turn their phone on for an hour, that's
when it will get triggered straight away.
So rather than trying to come up with a compromise
between which of these approaches to use,
why not use both?
Here we are going to specify a best-case scenario
where we are saying ideally we want to update
every 30 minutes, but if the device is on
standby, they are not using it anyway, we
can probably get by with updating only twice
day.
And then just set both of those alarms.
I assume you are all using inexact repeating
but this is an instance where you can improve
both freshness by having those nonwaking alarms
happening more frequently and the battery
life by pulling back on the wake alarms.
Now, that's a fairly straightforward approach.
What you can do, which is a little bit more
interesting is actually vary those particulars
values, the best case and worst case scenario
based on the device state.
Things like connectivity, whether the device
is docked, whether it's charging or the battery
is low.
All of these things should have an impact
on how frequently you want these alarms to
go off.
Let's have a look at each of them in sequence.
If we look at the connectivity, using the
connectivity manager we can check a couple
of things.
We can check to see whether we are connected
to the Internet at all.
If we're not connected to the Internet, you
can probably disable all of your refreshing
alarms.
Certainly the ones which are going to pull
data from the cloud.
If you don't have an Internet connection,
there's no point starting up the service running
the receivers so just disable it completely
until you get that connectivity back.
We can also check to see what kind of connection
we have.
If we're connected via Wi-Fi, we can probably
crank in number up.
It's cheaper, it's faster to get those updates,
whereas if we are on 2G mobile, again we probably
want to scale back.
We're talking about battery.
Let's have a look at the battery monitor.
So the way the battery manager works, it will
actually transmit a sticky broadcast, which
means we can co-register a receiver.
And even passing in a null receiver as we
have done here, we are still able to get the
last battery status which was broadcast.
In this instance all I am looking at is whether
the battery is being charged or it's full.
If the battery is being charged there is no
battery implication from doing your updates
more frequently.
So in that case you can make your worst case
scenario, your waking alarm, be equal to your
best-case scenario.
So you are going to wake the device every
30 minutes and get that update because you
don't have to worry about running the battery
down.
Docking state works the pretty much the same
way.
Here we are just checking to see whether the
device is docked or undocked.
You can also check to see whether it's in
a car dock, a desk dock, if it's digital or
an analog dock.
All these things are going to potentially
affect how frequently you do your updates.
And how you affect it will be entirely based
on your data.
So if what you are doing is checking road
conditions, then if it's in a car dock, you
probably want to do those updates pretty frequently,
whereas if it's in a desk dock, you may want
to slow them right down.
So again, it's a case of use the information
in a way that makes sense with your data.
And ultimately, that's what you want to do.
You want to take all these things into account.
We are on Wi-Fi, we are being charged, we
are in a desk dock.
If what my app does is check sports scores,
maybe during the game it makes sense to have
update every two minutes.
The same app in a car dock on a 2G mobile
network, which is actually decreasing in charge,
you probably want to disable that or at least
make it a lot less frequently.
The thing about device state is it is obviously
very dynamic.
So I have listed these all together.
They should obviously be separate intent filters
but effectively what we are saying you can
monitor to say has the dock being state changed.
You can't monitor the battery level in real
time but you can check to see whether you
are at a low battery state or whether the
device has been connected or disconnected
from power.
So this is a really important way that you
can modify how your app is behaving.
And probably the most important is the connectivity
change.
So check, if we lose Internet connection,
then disable all of your recurring alarms
and turn off a lot of your intent receivers.
You can also use this to put things off.
We have a 100 meg file we want to download.
We don't want to do that in 2G or 3G, so we
are going to set an alarm that says when you
have Wi-Fi connection, initiate that download.
So I said something there that you could enable
and disable your receivers.
That's actually something you can do even
from manifest receivers.
So within code at run time, you can actually
use the package manager, find out what is
the component name of your receiver class,
and then we're just going to enable or disable
it based on the conditions.
So for that connectivity example, you are
going to say, okay, when the connectivity
changes, if we have no active network, then
disable all of my state-change receivers because
there's no point running up my app if there's
nothing for it to do.
So be a good system citizen and disable all
of those things when they are not going to
be useful.
Most of these receivers, they are going to
trigger services to actually do the work of
pulling down the downloads.
Key here is everything needs to be done asynchronously.
I am going to already assume that your services
are asynchronous, that they are going to be
short-lived, they are going to be well behaved.
One of the things I wanted to highlight is
the ability to change the way that the onstart
command return result works.
So hopefully a lot of you already know you
can either return start sticky, which is going
to cause the system to keep restarting the
service should it need to kill it in order
to get some additional resources, and not
sticky is going to say if the system kills
it to regain memory right now, let it stay
dead.
What the little piece of code underneath does
is we're just going to have a look to say
when was the last time that it was successful?
How many times have we tried to run up this
service only for the system to kill it?
And what that lets us do is make this variable.
So we say if it's been longer than what we
consider to be an allowable period since it
last worked, force the system to make this
sticky, and otherwise let it die.
So it's a really easy way to make this dynamic
rather than a one-off compromise.
So that brings us to our next video, so please
cross your fingers.
[ Making noises ]
>>Reto Meier: So let's talk about how to make
your apps psychic.
What's a psychic app?
A psychic app knows things without you having
to explicitly tell it.
It's like a stage magician.
It just seems to know things which you probably
told it at some point, but you didn't realize
it would be usable in this circumstance.
And it's the same thing with forgetting things.
It never forgets anything.
What does that mean in practice?
Before I get into that, I want to point out
that a psychic app has a potential of being
a very creepy app.
It's very important if you are using this
information to be very aware of how this impacts
user privacy.
You don't want them to go, "How did you know
that?"
You want them to be like, "Oh, great.
That's excellent.
I don't need to complete this again."
So it's really important to make sure users
understand where the data is coming from and
how it's getting used.
So one of the ways you can do that is using
the account manager.
That already has the login names and e-mail
addresses people have used to login accounts
on the phone.
This is really useful information.
You can actually go through and extract each
of these account names.
Now, to do that, you do need to have the get
accounts permission so the user will be asked
are you willing to let this app get permission
to your account data.
Now, this is a good example where you need
to consider what the payoffs are.
Is it going to make sense or are they going
to say "know understand why a wallpaper app
needs to see my account permissions."
Be conscious of that.
Make sure it makes sense in your instance.
Tweetdeck is a great example of an app which
does this really, really well, to suggest
the user names for each of the services which
you can sign in, Twitter, four square, Facebook,
et cetera, and Tweetdeck itself.
It suggests them all as auto completions when
you are putting in your data.
It makes it easier, it makes sense in that
instance.
We talked about never forgetting anything.
So this is across the board.
If you have got a native app which has an
equivalent Web app, make sure those preferences
are synced.
They shouldn't have to put in the same data
again.
You already know who they are.
They have given you that information once.
It should be synced across those devices.
If users aren't logged in, well, we already
talked earlier in the day about how to create
a universal unique identifier so you can track
an installation anonymously, so you are still
able to back up that information on your server.
And then when the user does create a login,
that shouldn't wipe their preferences.
It should all sync together so that their
phone-based preferences are now applied to
their new Web-based account.
So what happens, though, if you'd like to
back up this information but you don't have
a server to back up with?
Well, you can actually use one which we prepared
earlier.
So using the backup manager, you can back
up shared preferences to our cloud-based backup
service.
So this is all entirely opt in.
You note when you opt into your device it
asks do you want to backup your information.
If you say yes it will remember what apps
you downloaded and it will redownload for
them if you wipe your device.
In some cases if you get a new device, it
will download those apps automatically which
is really handy.
So using the Android backup service, you are
able to persist additional information into
the cloud as well, so that when they back
up their apps, you are also backing up your
application data alongside it.
So if the device does get wiped, you are able
to not only get your apps back but the preferences
for all of those apps as well.
Really handy.
Now, you might remember -- Sorry.
Before I go on, I should say this is how it
actually works.
So for shared preferences in particular, we've
made this as simple as possible.
So you can see we are creating a backup agent
helper, and within on create, which is this
bit here, we are creating a new shared preferences
backup helper.
This is really straightforward.
We're specifying the name of the shared preferences
file, which we have defined at the top here,
that's just user preferences, and we are adding
a helper for each of the keys you want to
back up.
In this instance, you probably don't want
to be persisting instance information, like
application state.
You want to be persisting only user preferences,
and so this is how you can define exactly
which of those keys within the shared preference
file you want to back up.
To make that work, you need to add a new attribute
to your application node specifying your backup
agent and you need to also have a meta data
tag which has your API key for the backup
service.
So as I was saying earlier, you saw how we
create this universal unique ID.
We actually did all of that by storing it
as a shared preference.
So what that means is that now you can use
this in combination with a backup manager
to persist that installation identifier, if
the user has opted in, so that if the device
gets wiped, they get their preferences back,
and they get their universally unique identifier
back.
So any preferences that you have saved on
your server side are going to be consistent
on this new device or after it's been flashed.
It's very easy for user to opt out or to clear
their data so there's limit privacy concerns
but again, you want to be aware of what you
are storing on the server and how that's going
to be identifiable to users.
The last psychic tip is something which has
existed since the very beginning but a disappointingly
large number of people haven't been taking
advantage of can and that's intercepting links
to content.
So you have seen this before.
Google Maps, YouTube.
You follow a link, it asks you do you want
to view this in the native app or use the
browser?
You can do exactly the same thing and it's
as simple as adding this data node or data
attribute within the intent filter node of
the activity which is able to handle that
content.
So here I am specifying a particular Web site
with a prefix to a path.
Every time someone clicks on that link it's
going to ask if I would like to use my activity
to view it.
If you have built a native app and it's not
the best way to view your content, then I've
got some pretty serious questions about why
you bothered to build a native app to begin
with.
All right?
So make sure that it is the best way to view
your content, and then make it available to
your users.
All right.
Next video.
[ Making noises ]
[ Laughter ]
>>Reto Meier: I want to talk about making
your apps adaptive.
So what's an adaptive app?
Well, it's one which doesn't stick out in
ways that you don't want it to; right?
It should be invisible to the user.
Now, I'm not saying you shouldn't have an
app which stands out.
It should.
You should create something unique and interesting
and innovative.
But all the things which you take for granted
text input, audio behavior, all of those things
should just happen the way users expect them
to happen.
And that's what being adaptive is all about.
So let's start off by looking at one of the
most simple things, and that's text input.
Make sure that the right keyboard comes up
when the user is putting things into the edit
text.
So you have a number of options.
It can be plain text, it can be a number,
it can be a phone number, it can be a date
or time.
And each of these are going to have different
ideal ways of putting in data.
The way you specify that is simply by setting
the input type within each of your edit text
so they show the right kind of input.
So in this case we are putting phone.
That's going to show you the traditional phone
dialer, because that's going to be the easiest
way to input phone information.
So this is all handled by the IME.
You just need to tell it what kind of input
you want.
In the case of text input, you have the option
of URIs, email addresses, people's names.
This is going to change not only what's available
on the keyboard, but the kind of entry.
For people's names, you want auto correction
only to come from the contact page and you
want to have each word capitalized.
All of this stuff is going to be variable.
You're going to be able to specify that by
specifying what kind of text you want to use.
Here we are's specifying e-mail and URI.
At the bottom left of your keyboard, sometimes
you see a little .com symbol or a little @ symbol
to make it more easy to type in a Web address
or an email address, and that is the attribute
which is controlling that.
When you are doing text input, you can actually
add another level of flags which are going
to have a much greater level of customization.
You can control capitalization, auto correction,
and multiline input.
And, in fact, in this example, that's exactly
what we're doing.
We're specifying that we want auto correction
turned on, capitalize the sentences, and we
want to support multiline input.
You know we've actually specified the maximum
length of the string and the maximum number
of lines as well.
The other thing you can do with the keyboard
is actually specify an action which should
be initiated by the user when they're entering
text.
And so this is something you'll see in the
bottom right of the keyboard.
If it's multiline text, it's the enter key.
Otherwise, it's going to be either the "done"
or next -- it's going to say "done" or "next"
depending whether there's another field for
the user to move on to next.
I want to think about specifying that explicitly.
If you have a browser or an instant messaging
client or Twitter client, it will make more
sense to say "send?"
So the user doesn't have to close the action
and then initiate the action.
He can do it all within the keyboard display.
So this is how you do that.
So you set the IME rather than the input type,
and you can see here we specified the send
action.
In this case, we've actually said if we do
have a hardware keyboard, something which
has a solid enter key, I don't want that to
represent send, because something like that
you probably want the user to explicitly hit
the button rather than just pressing "enter."
This is something that you can control and
you should control, so that it makes sense,
given your context.
If you are doing that sort of thing, obviously,
you need to then listen for those button clicks
so that it actually does something when the
user presses the action.
That's what we're looking at here.
We're simply going to create a new editor
action listener, listen for a particular key
press and then do something accordingly, straightforward.
The next thing, that's your keyboard.
Your keyboard's pimped out, doing everything
it should be.
The next thing I wanted to talk about is to
have a look at how you can handle audio.
So there's a number of different ways that
audio is going to be impacted by your app.
You're going to have volume control, you're
going to have playback buttons on Bluetooth
and wide keyboards.
And you're going to have audio focus.
So there's background apps.
Multiple media players can all be playing
at once.
How do you decide which is playing, which
is listening to those playback buttons, and
whose volume is getting controlled.
Volume control is actually really simple.
On Android by default, the volume keys are
going to control whatever media stream is
playing.
So if you've got a game or a media player
and it's not playing audio, it's going to
default back to the ringer.
So in most cases, what you want to do is call
this within your oncreate.
And that's going to assure that every time
you hit the video controls -- I should say
every time you hit the volume controls, it's
going to adjust the stream, the music stream
volume.
A real easy way to produce something which
is much more intuitive to use is media buttons
are a little bit more complicated.
It's all intent-based so you want to specify
a manifest receiver that says I'm interested
in listening for media buttons.
Create your broadcast receiver.
And then simply listen.
And that's the red highlighted text.
We're looking at what button got pressed.
So play, stop, pause, skip, et cetera.
We mentioned that there are a number of devices
which could potentially be listening for these
media button clicks.
So using this code, you're able to then say,
okay, now is when I want to actually listen
for those play button clicks or stop button
clicks.
Now, naively, you could put these in the unresume
or unpause methods of your activities.
That's probably not what you want.
You still want to be listening to those even
if your app is in the background.
You only want to stop listening to them if
another app is doing the play back.
The way to handle that is by listening for
audio focus changes.
As soon as you want your app to be the main
application playing back audio, you request
the audio focus.
You specify the stream which you're using
to play back that audio.
Music is going to be almost always what you
are specifying.
And here we're saying that we want to take
control of the audio permanently.
As an alternative, we can actually say we
only want to do it transiently.
Take control for a brief instance, play some
music, and then return control back.
In that case, the listening app is going to
want to continue to listen to the play, stop,
you know, pause buttons.
When we've finished play back, we abandon
audio focus which tells the system somebody
else is in charge of playing back audio.
Flip side of that is the change listener.
This is how you listen to find out when another
app has taken control.
If your app is playing back music, someone
launches something else, they hit play, your
app should stop play back and should stop
listening for the media button controls because
someone else is doing it now.
The most basic case is audio focus loss, which
is this one here.
This corresponds to the audio focus gain call
when someone is requesting audio focus.
There's two additional variations.
And that's highlighted here.
You can then -- the calling app can actually
say, look, it's only going to be transient.
I'm just going to play something back very
briefly.
I want you to continue to have focus after
that.
So in that instance, you probably want to
hit "pause."
As an alternative, say, for example, if you
are listening to an app which is giving you
turn-by-turn navigation, saying I want to
turn left in 50 meters, you want to hear that
but don't necessarily want to pause play back
of music.
You want to lower volume.
That's called ducking.
You can say it's transient and duck.
So rather than pausing, just lower the volume.
That's what we're listening for here.
Really simple tip for adaptive apps which
is a really easy one, and surprisingly few
people do it, is providing translations for
your app title and descriptions in the Android
Market.
This is a really simple one.
You're probably thinking, it's okay, a lot
of Android users, they're bilingual, they're
quite happy to use my app.
It's not that much text, anyway.
It's a game.
It's fine.
That's probably true.
But when they're searching for your app in
the Android Market, there's a very good chance
they'll be using their native language.
So rather than having to do your entire app,
which you should still do, you can start by
simply giving a really good, accurate translation
for your title and description.
Make it that much more discoverable for users
who aren't native English speakers.
In the few minutes remaining, the last section,
last video.
[ Video.
]
>>Reto Meier: It's about making your apps
smooth.
So what do we mean by smooth?
All right.
So a smooth app is exactly that.
Everything feels like it's running on rails.
It's a lot of the stuff that Chet and Romain
were talking about in the previous system.
It's about using animations, making things
fast and efficient.
You should never have to pause for anything.
A key to that is really making everything
asynchronous, really with no exceptions.
Why is that?
If it's not interacting with the UI thread,
it shouldn't be happening on the UI thread
or the main application thread, as it's otherwise
known.
A 16-millisecond delay can cause a jatter
on a 60-frame-per-second animation, and that
jatter is going to make a user think that
things aren't working the way that they should.
So it's really important that you make your
apps as efficient as possible and put things
in the background as much as you can.
Now, as experts, I'm sure that a lot of these
classes are already quite familiar to you
guys.
Hopefully, AsyncTask and intent services are
mainstays of your arsenal.
But I did want to point out a couple of relatively
new classes.
That's the abstract loader class and the implementation
of the cursor loader.
These are both part of Honeycomb.
They're actually available, like Fragments,
as an external API.
So you can use these to improve your app performance
today.
Now, the code looks a little bit scary.
It's not actually as complicated as you might
think.
We're going to start off by getting an instance
of the loader manager.
That's what's going to let us do the work.
And then everything -- all the magic happens
here.
So oncreate loader.
Now, the cursor loader, which we're call there
the constructor with all those null strings,
this is essentially where you're able to construct
the cursor, which you want to load in a background
thread.
The base URI there is the key.
That's the base URI to the content provider
which you want to extract content from.
And you can specify selection, projections,
"where" clauses, all of those things, as you
would if you were using a content resolvers
to extract a query in the traditional sense.
Once the loading is finished, that cursor
data is going to be populated and it's going
to be passed back into your application.
So all of that loading will be done in the
background.
You don't have to worry about what parts of
the content resolution process happen on the
foreground or the background thread.
This does it all for you.
Then you get your cursor and apply it to your
adapter or do whatever else you need to do
with that data.
So how do you know if you've done it right?
Well, you start off by using strict mode.
Hopefully, again, you've all used this, are
familiar with it.
Great way to be able to find out if anything
like disk reads, writes, network action any
of that is happening on the foreground thread
and fixing it.
I do want to point out it's a development
tool.
You do want to have it so it only runs on
the development version.
Should make a difference because you have
fixed all these things before you release.
Just in case they do slip through, turn it
off for the runtime version.
You don't want the screen flashing or dialogue
boxes of the burst logging or any of that
stuff on your release builds.
So turn it off.
So that's it.
That's all of the extra attributes I wanted
to go through today.
Hopefully, I've given you enough information
so that most of you guys in this piece of
the pie can become this piece of the pie.
And, hopefully, you'll be able to come away
with some ideas of how to make your device
-- how to make your applications fresh, Psychic,
adaptive, and smooth.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>>Reto Meier: Now, I think we do have some
time.
I think we're heading into lunch, but we do
have a few minutes left for questions.
If you do have any in the room, head up to
the mike.
And I have a few on the moderator page as
well.
Lunch wins.
All right.
I'll read these out because I don't think
we're going to get them on the screen.
Do we have any tips for working with SQLLite
databases through Eclipse?
At the minute, I rely on external tools to
view data that is in the database on the phone.
No tips.
That is all you're going to have to do.
Eclipse is a wonderful development tool.
However, it is clunky.
How many of you use Eclipse?
Yeah, how many of you think it's clunky?
Yeah.
It is.
So we're going to do a bunch of stuff.
So there's some sessions tomorrow, or, indeed,
later today, about the Android development
tools.
Should definitely check that out, there's
great information there about how to use those
tools more effectively.
>>> About that cursor loader, if you use that
to -- yeah, so -- do things asynchronously,
but you need the cursor to fill the activities
or a way to save data away into the database,
you cannot really use that.
You need to have it done immediately, because
the work flow of the app requires that you
continue; right?
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
So what you would do is you would have the
cursor loader is going to get a new cursor,
which you would then swap out for your adapter.
So for most cases, what you have is a view,
like a ListView, which has an adapter backing
it.
Then you can call swap adapter and it's just
going to exchange the new cursor with the
old one.
>>> That's assuming you have an old one.
So the first one needs to be done synchronously,
then.
>>Reto Meier: No, you still do it asynchronously
you still do your ListView with nothing in
it and then wait until you have that data
and then start to populate it.
Yeah.
>>> So you mentioned the connectivity provider
or connectivity messaging.
I was curious.
We were using that, and it seems like you
will go in and out of connectivity on a frequent
basis.
How expensive is that to wake up, let you
know that you've entered connectivity, but
it's not the right type, or things like that?
>>Reto Meier: Sure, absolutely.
So you want to keep it as lightweight as possible.
So you want to have a receiver, possibly one
which is happening in a separate process to
the rest of your application so that your
whole app isn't necessarily getting spun up
each time.
Then you want that to be as lightweight as
possible of just checking to see what the
connectivity change is.
>>> But that would be a separate process within
the same APK?
>>Reto Meier: Yes.
Yeah.
>>> Thank you.
>>Reto Meier: No problem.
>>> In your first discussion, there is a lot
of things you can register for the event,
such as low battery and the change in those
things; right?
>>Reto Meier: Uh-huh.
>>> And those things should have dependency
or priority or contribute to each other sometimes.
Is there any way you can define what those
things that need to be done by the receiver?
>>Reto Meier: I guess you can define that
within your receiver to basically receive
--
>>> In that case, the receiver can have a
-- can be bigger and bigger.
For example, they cannot just check low battery,
because they need to also check the connectivity
sometimes; right?
>>Reto Meier: So you can do that within the
receiver.
Within the receiver, you are just getting
triggered by changing connectivity.
>>> Is there a good way you can also define
those dependency or priority when you register
those things?
>>Reto Meier: No.
No simple way.
The --
>>> Not simple way, but you can -- that will,
like, reduce those event, basically, right?
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>> Otherwise, have a lot of different events,
and then everything is up to application,
then may cause some problem; right?
>>Reto Meier: That's absolutely true.
You do need to be aware of the fact that if
you have 12 different receivers all listening
for common things, it's going to have its
own impact on battery life.
>>> If you can have an additional API for
that, that would be good, too.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
I'll pass it on to the team.
Yes.
>>> You mentioned the passive location provider.
How different is that from -- in the freshness
sense of view, from getting last-known position?
Like, I mean, you're going to get the same
data; right?
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
It depends how you want to use it.
The passive location provider is better if
you plan on doing something with that data
while you're in the background.
So if all you're going to do is say, look,
I don't want to do anything in the background,
I just want to wait until the app starts and
then get the last known location, you're better
off using that.
Whereas if you're saying well, I actually
want to say every 15 minutes, every half hour
if the location is changed, I want to get
that data.
So as soon as the app starts, it has that
current information.
That has, obviously, a very significant battery
impact.
But that would be the difference between the
two.
>>> Thanks.
>>Reto Meier: Have a quick look on the moderator.
You better mention better not to lose your
sign-in key, but how to update your app when
your (inaudible) expired.
(inaudible) a certificate with a very long
expiry date.
That's the reason you can't sign your certificates
with a debug key, because the expirations
are too short.
We will worry about how to transition them
in 2050, when most of them should have expired.
Please.
>>> Hypothetically speaking, if we created
an application and deployed it under our personal
GMail account, is there anything that we can
do now to move that to another account?
>>Reto Meier: No.
[ Applause ]
>>Reto Meier: That is a good question.
>>> (inaudible) fresh application?
>>Reto Meier: The only thing you can do right
now is unpublish the app, create a new one,
and publish it.
It would be nice if you could transition or
invite other people into a particular application.
It's not something that's available now.
But we are talking about -- some of the guys
who are doing improvements on market are going
to give a presentation.
I don't think that's changed since the last
time I heard, but they would be the right
folks to ask.
Do developers at Google use any hardware emulators
to speed up development.
Could you please recommend one.
We use actual hardware where we have it.
And we are trying to improve the emulator.
So, again, check out the talk on developer
tools, and hopefully there will be some news
there.
Yes.
>>> For various reasons, we're thinking of
distributing our app on the SD card.
And that will be installed in the Android
phones.
So is there, like, an Eclipse way to download
that and how to do that mechanism?
>>Reto Meier: I don't think I understand.
>>> So we're thinking of physically -- it's
kind of a weird thing, but we're physically
thinking of distributing the app on the SD
card.
>>Reto Meier: Okay.
>>> And then, you know, going to salespeople
and then putting it in their phones and then
running the app that way instead of downloading.
>>Reto Meier: No, there's nothing supported
for that.
So you could potentially install it from the
SD card by navigating it using a file manager
on the device.
But there's no simple way of doing that.
Yes.
>>> Hi.
Thank you.
Does the location manager -- when you register
for location updates, does it, like, hold
a WakeLock?
Or let's say you want to run continuous location
tracking, and I know it's not a good thing,
and we're not doing this for, like, a consumer
app, it's for a research app.
Do we have to, like, have a long list service
that holds the WakeLock that will, you know,
be alive the whole time that is listening
for the location updates?
Or if we just register location updates, will
that, like, you know, keep the server -- keep
the service alive automatically?
In practice, we've noticed it seems like the
service never dies, even if we don't hold
the WakeLock, but --
>>Reto Meier: It's hard to kill services.
And because they by default will get restarted
automatically for something like a location
listener, it works.
If it's music, then you'll hear a pause as
the service gets killed and the system restarts
it.
So that's why you want to make that an ongoing
activity.
Generally, I think if you register a location
listener using the intent mechanism, that
is sort of independent of any running application.
So that receiver is always going to get triggered.
Generally speaking, you do want to have a
service which continues to deliver good form
in an ongoing service so users can see that.
>>> What about the WakeLock aspect of it?
If you register with the intent mechanism,
do you need to -- will that, like, --
>>Reto Meier: You'll need to create -- so
the intent receiver will run for -- I think
it has a WakeLock for -- within the on receive
action, to be completed within, I think, ten
seconds.
So anything which is happening outside of
that, you would need to have a WakeLock for
the service to continue.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
>>Reto Meier: No problem.
>>> And do you mind me asking, what are you
using for the presentation?
What app?
>>Reto Meier: For the -- the app for the presentation
was something I hand-created.
So if -- including the video crashing, if
you are interested, I'll be looking to open
source that at some time in the future.
>>> That would be awesome.
Thanks.
>>Reto Meier: All right.
>>> Do you have any tips how to optimize compatibility
on Web views?
Because some of the versions of the browser
are broken on the JavaScript bridges and other
stuff.
>>Reto Meier: Not my area, but check out the
Chrome team's office hours.
They are the browser experts, so it's not
a Chrome browser, but they do know all about,
you know, browsers and those sorts of things.
And some of the mobile guys will be able to
give you some advice.
Cool.
Thanks very much, everyone.